Caucasian.
That word comes to us from a rugged land where Europe smacks into Asia,
sandwiched between countries and always grab headlines.
Russia,
Iran,
Turkey.
But here's a headline for you.
This little area is one of the world's great linguistic hot zones,
a place where the mountains are full of languages.
Welcome to the caucuses.
Yay.
Georgia is a US state that's about 300 miles tall with a population over 10
million.
Most everyone here speaks one language.
English.
I turned off the global way.
Straddling the south east of Europe is a country we called Turkey and east of
Turkey.
There's another Georgia watch.
What happens when I take Georgia and put it over Georgia?
There's a lot more Georgia left.
It leaks into Russia and over into Azerbaijan.
It even covers part of Armenia and Turkey.
Whole these borders between the Black Sea and the Caspian Sea,
but these are nothing compared to the number of languages here.
As the Kurdish saying goes,
we have no friends but the mountains,
I don't know Kurdish or the more than 50 languages of the caucuses,
but Kurdish is a distant relative of the words I'm speaking right now.
It's in the Iranian branch of our Indo European family,
which is something it's shares with the Scythians last descended on [inaudible].
You can hear echoes of familiar words.
I like the word for door diddy wad in Armenia.
Adore sounds similar door,
but Armenian is a separate Indo European branch.
They're unique.
Alphabet was created by this gentleman,
scholar Mr Mush totes making Armenian,
one of the rare languages in the region with its own old writings.
Some Armenians claim mush.
Totes also taught the Georgians how to write a Georgians beg to differ.
Armenian splits another language down the middle in this disputed turf.
We're the name you give it and whether you call the fighting in the nineties
liberation or occupation is 10th stuff.
This other language belongs to the country with the world's lowest capital,
nearly 100 feet,
30 meters below sea level.
Azerbaijani.
After all that Indo European,
it looks strange unless you know Turkish.
The Turkic family has multiple branches all over the Caucasus.
It builds long words with glued on endings were the vowels harmonize a lot like
Hungarian.
Remember things aren't so Turkic up here in Europe,
only Buddhist region.
This is called Makia,
a Russian republic settled by oil rots who speak a relative of Mongolian.
So there's Mongolia here,
there's Hellenic here,
caucuses,
Greek.
There's Semitic a Syrian,
neo,
Aramaic.
But there was one obvious blob we ignored.
Come on.
Who brings the big guns into this area?
Metaphorically speaking,
of course,
Russian in the Slavic branch of Indo European
a couple of years ago,
Russia held the Winter Olympics in the city of Sochi drama and sued.
What attracted a lot of press was the exorbitant cost,
but there's another controversy you may have missed.
Ethnic [inaudible] have long considered Sochi their land taken in the 18
hundreds when the Russian empire vowed to conquer the Caucasus and pacify or
expel every indigenous group.
One of the men in that army was Leo Tolstoy and this is where he tasted.
Warren started writing
the last speaker of Sochi Oobleck language died in Turkey in 1992 with him
parish,
the largest consonant inventory outside of Africa,
over three times as many as English and just to be extreme,
only two basic vowels.
Ah,
and Ah,
this is the kind of special stuff that keeps language nerds infatuated with
indigenous Caucasian languages.
Indigenous means something special here.
See for linguists,
there are languages of the caucuses and then Caucasian languages.
These smaller families born in and limited to the caucuses.
Few vowels,
many consonants including throaty sounds Ah,
ah,
English has one such sound Arabic,
several,
no competition for these Caucasian tongs.
Oh,
and they probably had even more in the past,
but the real Caucasian hot topic came from one example in an old grammar of
Silva Touche.
There was an intransitive verb with the subject that could resemble an object.
I fell and it was my fault,
like on purpose versus fell me on accident.
It sounds simple,
but the implications were huge.
This example fell into the right hands and the concept of Ergot tivity became a
linguistic rockstar
in 1770 a German naturalist set out on an expedition to the caucuses,
trekking with a royal cub Ardian and Georgian entourage.
He took notes and divided Caucasian languages into four families,
each one with its own prodo language.
And he did this over a decade before,
a well known speech by Sir William Jones that drew attention to classifying into
European.
Later there did come a one family fits all,
pushed to bundle them into I bureau Caucasian.
The idea ultimately failed to win converts.
Today we count three families northwest,
northeast,
south,
the Self Cart velien includes Jorgen and indigenous language with its own
ancient literature.
And the reason why Joseph Stalin a native Georgian had HUD accent patterns in
his speeches.
So the two Stowe,
that's in northeast Caucasian of family native to the border republics of
Dagestan and Chechnya.
Chechen has an oddly large number of vowels for Caucasian language.
This line marks or republic where they speak a Georgian dialect.
They're on good terms but not so in these dots where they broke away in 1992
with 13 months of ethnic strife.
The local up cause is part of northwest Caucasian,
the family of [inaudible] and your old consonant,
full friend Rubik.
This family has been blamed for making Caucasian hard to classify.
See,
they have these roots with one measly consonant and they do something called
head marking.
As a result,
they can lose.
Resemblance is more quickly making it harder to compare them and find siblings.
Caucasian isn't one family,
is it one area though?
Yeah.
Perhaps the languages co-existed long enough to pick up each other's habits.
Snot out of the question.
We saw how it happened in Mesoamerica still debated if this even fits for the
caucuses.
So maybe not a language area,
but definitely an area with lots of languages and you still gotta be wondering
why,
why so many
Joanna Nichols tells us the answer may not be on the speaker's lips,
but under their feet.
Geography gives some families spread zones,
easy terrain for expanding.
Other terrains are residuals,
zones,
holding languages in place.
Which zone is responsible here?
I hope you said both languages from the lowlands flow into the area.
Then the mountains keep them.
So the three Caucasian families survived in place and didn't spread beyond
overtime.
Others pass through and got stuck and the diversity grew.
We end up with this map,
a map of more than 50 languages across seven families,
each splash of color with its own stories to tell,
stick around and subscribe for links.